you come from above
like him
he will burn the world to find you
oh
the Conqueror
Kang the Conqueror is the new iconic
villain in the MCU
we knew we wanted to go to places that
we'd never been and hitting Ant-Man
against a major villain felt perfect
audiences have seen a version of this
character in the series Loki
this is wild
in our film he's very different Kang is
an infinite number of different personas
and you need an actor to be able to pull
that off and that is Jonathan Majors I
can rewrite existence and shatter
timelines in this film this is really a
side of him we haven't seen this is his
baddest self I will take my revenge on
those who banished me and I will burn
them out of time
I think the film is ultimately about how
time plays within our relationship
love friendship Legacy Ant-Man versus
tank this is it people gonna lose their
mind
the hell of your league Ant-Man
[Music]
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot of new Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania footage to
break down these new scenes are epic and
they mainly highlight Kang now I am
going to the world premiere tonight so
be sure to look out for my reaction
video a quick little reaction coming out
of the theater watching it I'm pretty
sure I'm going to be reacting most to
Ant-Man and his entire family of course
I'm super excited to see them but I'm
really excited to see King the Conqueror
and in this new footage they do show us
a bit of his powers as well this is the
first trailer that I really feel Marvel
Studios is really diving into how Kang
the Conqueror is the next big bad he is
the villain of this Saga and now in
these TV spots and trailers they are
showing more of his powers and showing
just how strong he actually is he's not
just an Ant-Man villain but he's the
next villain and one of the first things
that Marvel Studios president Kevin
feige and Paul Rudd talks about is
something very very important the king
that we are seeing in Ant-Man and the
WASP of quantumania is a variant of he
who remains from Loki Paul Rudd states
that we've seen a version of him before
and something to keep in mind is that it
is a different version so this character
is not going to be the same he who
remains was very different he didn't
really want to conquer he simply wanted
to keep his variants away from him and
the timeline but Kang is very different
in quantumania even the opening scene of
this new footage says the Conqueror will
come for you Paul Rudd says that he's
very different and then Kevin feige
explains that Kang is an infinite number
of different personas basically telling
us that each King the Conqueror is not
the same because keep in mind during the
Multiverse Saga during all of these
events that are taking place before
Secret Wars and during Secret Wars we're
going to see multiple versions of King
but what's really cool about that is
Michelle Pfeiffer says that this is a
sight of King that we've never seen this
is his baddest self so although we'll be
seeing in other kings in the MCU this
one in Ant-Man and the wasp's
quantumania is most likely the big bad
the one that will conquer the other
kangs and the Avengers and the
Multiverse and that's where Secret Wars
comes in that's where the Avengers team
up with all of the other teams across
the Multiverse to defeat this one Kang
now there are a few new scenes that we
really need to talk about one is we have
a scene where Kang says that people
banished him he says I will take my
revenge on those who banished me and I
will burn them out of time now one this
scene is just awesome because it looks
like Jonathan Majors is really nailing
the part just by what we've seen in the
trailer so far but two it kind of shows
us the true power of King the Conqueror
because an Avengers end game we learned
that you just can't simply go back in
time change something and then the
future changes according to the science
and Avengers end game that is not how it
works it simply creates a branched
timeline an alternate timeline that is
why the Avengers couldn't go back in
time and simply kill Thanos that
wouldn't array race him from existence
it would start a new timeline but Kang
here is saying that he will literally
take people out of existence so it takes
much more than just going back in time
to actually do that but Kang has the
power we hear him say it here and we've
heard in the other trailers and TV spots
Janet Van Dyne say that he can erase
entire timelines from existence so Kang
truly has power over time he is the
Conqueror of time now there is another
scene that's new that is very
interesting it's of Ant-Man and his
daughter Cassie in prison cells that
Kang is holding them in however Cassie
as we can see is already in her suit now
the reason that this is interesting and
keep in mind Marvel Studios can be a
little deceptive with their trailers of
course they've done that in the past but
based off of what the other trailers
have kind of showed us this could
actually be a different kangware scene
in this shot right here because this
seems like they could have already
talked to Kang or at least a variant of
King the one that is saying you'll do
what I want or or I'll kill your family
and what we believe is going to happen
is that Ant-Man might have to steal from
a different King so this could be that
other king this could be Scott Lang and
his daughter Cassie trying to take
something from Kang but actually getting
caught or this simply could be when they
get caught for the first time but it is
very interesting that Cassie already has
her suit on because we don't see it on
her really in any other TV spots they're
trying to save that for a pretty big
reveal in the movie now another thing
that's showcased in this new footage is
some of King's Powers we have a scene
here where Kang moves his arm and
Ant-Man flies up against the wall
showing us that Kang seemingly has the
power of telekinesis however if you take
a look at his arm he is seemingly
wearing some type of a gauntlet and it
glows blue when he moves Scott Lang this
is important because Kang the Conqueror
or I should say his original name
Nathaniel Richards doesn't actually have
any powers himself he's not a mutant
born with superpowers he doesn't have
powers himself but he does have
technology if you've been following our
videos we've talked about this a lot but
since Kang is the time traveler the
master of time he can go forward into
the future centuries into the future and
get highly Advanced Weaponry in fact
Kang or Nathaniel before he started as
Kang was originally born in the 30th
Century so he was already from the
future to begin with so he has
technology and weapons from the future
that are just way more advanced than
anything our Avengers have seen so what
he's doing here is using future
technology to use telekinesis he also
has the power to manipulate and harness
energy and I'm assuming it's going to be
Quantum energy in this movie since they
are in the quantum realm and it's called
quantumania and they actually gave us a
really cool scene here in this clip of
Kang using that energy in a big battle
now what we really have to talk about is
the banishing part where Kang says he
will take those that banished him and
get his revenge there are a few people
that he could be talking about and he
could be talking about more than one and
one of them that is most likely is
probably Janet Van Dyne we know that her
and Kang have a history we know that
it's a bad history but it didn't start
off as a bad history so perhaps Janet
did something that further trapped Kang
inside of the quantum realm and she
could be one of those people he is
talking about and this could also make
Kang want to go to our main timeline and
kill it the main MCU Earth 616 timeline
where all of our main Avengers are this
is how the Kang Dynasty is probably
going to come into play and tell us why
this specific Kang who was trapped
inside of the quantum realm came to our
specific universe so I'm guessing that
one of those people he's talking about
is Janet Van Dyne another person or I
should say people that he could be
talking about is the Council of Kings
now I did a video about the Council of
kings around four days ago and the
Council of Kings is pretty much what it
sounds like it's a group of kings that
get together and they essentially
monitor the Multiverse to make sure it
goes the way they want it to this
includes sometimes helping out other
kangs if they're foe usually The
Avengers are growing too strong but a
big part of what they do is actually
judge other kangs and they make sure
that each member is worthy of the name
Kang and perhaps our King the Conqueror
that we see here in the trailers in
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania perhaps
he was judged by the council and not
deemed worthy or he was deemed as a
threat to them they could have feared
that he would conquer them and conquer
the entire Multiverse itself so in turn
they could have banished him to the
quantum realm outside of time outside of
space with maybe at the time no way to
get back and since Captain feige has
already told us that the Kang Dynasty in
secret Wars isn't just about Kang vs The
Avengers and the heroes but it's about
Kang versus his variants as well this
could very well be the case this could
be what we find out in Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania because I'm assuming
we'll get a little bit of backstory
about Kang but in the meantime before it
comes out let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news for live updates
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf